(mouse clicks)
(electronic beep)
(bright piano music)
- [Man] We are the paradoxical apes.
Bipedal. Naked, large brains.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insight on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible by
the generosity of humans like you.
(upbeat music)
- People with synesthesia
experience the ordinary world
in quite extraordinary ways.
For some people when they
look at letters on the page,
each letter might have
its own distinctive color,
which either appears in
the synesthete's mind eye
or is perhaps projected onto the page
on top of the regular text.
For other synesthetes, time
and the calendar for example,
or numbers are seen visio-spatially
as kind of an undulating landscape.
This might serve as a memory aid.
For example, we see it
in the case of Jill Price
that was presented earlier.
Not only has she got fantastic
autobiographical memory,
she perceives the years in terms of
her own internal landscape of time.
This is one of my first
case studies of synesthesia
and this is a man who takes words, as he's
listening to me speak
now, each word might have
its own distinct flavor on his mouth.
And this is his representation
of the London tube map,
the Underground, and words to him might
taste of celery or of sausage meat.
He grew up in Britain in
the 1960s, where this was
your quintessential
kind of diet growing up,
so he's internalized
this in his synesthesia.
One of the first case
studies that points to
extraordinary ability in
synesthesia is this book by Luria
called The Mind of a
Mnemonist, and this is somebody
who was described as
having an infinite memory.
He never forgets things, he can remember
sequences of abstract syllables
that are presented to him
and the recalls them
years later, and also has
phenomenal autobiographical
memory as well.
As well as having amazing memory, he also
had various kinds of synesthesia,
so numbers would elicit colors,
the sound of somebody's voice would have
both colors, taste and touch,
so he had a multiplicity of
different kinds of synesthesia.
And this is a case that
we've already heard about,
who has both synesthesia
and Asperger's Syndrome,
high-functioning Autism.
So Daniel could recite pi
to 20,000 decimal places,
a feat which takes
around five hours just to
say the digits aloud, but what he's doing
when he's recalling them
is also extraordinary,
because for him the digits
is not just a verbal string,
it's a visio-spatial
string that he reads off
from his mind's eye, and
this is representation
of the first 20 digits of pi.
For him, each digit has
its own particular color,
and its own particular texture
and its own position in the
sequence that he reads off
as he's recollecting the sequence.
So these are extraordinary cases,
is synesthesia in general
linked to enhanced memory
and if so, why might this be?
What we know about synesthetes is that
they have differences in their brain,
although theses aren't well-characterized.
It's more gray matter and more
white-matter organization,
at least patchy within some regions.
One possibility is that
you could use synesthesia
as a kind of a memory aid.
IF you see words spelled out, then it
might help you to remember them.
You're using the synesthesia
as a kind of cognitive tool.
The other possibility is
that it's something about
the brain changes
themselves that give rise
not only to synesthesia,
but also give rise to other
particular cognitive phenotypes
such as enhanced memory.
I'll argue in favor of this and present
various lines of evidence.
So first of all, if we
look at the memory ability
of people with synesthesia,
these are people
who experience words
and letters as colors,
and we would give them a
standard recognition memory test
in which we'd present them
with a sequence of say,
30 words to remember, and then a test
we'd present them with
60 words, half of which
they saw before and half
of which they didn't,
and we made them visually
similar to try and confuse them.
And of course they were
presented in a random order,
not consecutively like this.
But at the end of all tests, what strategy
did he use for memorizing them?
And actually when we back-sort people
by the kind of strategy they have,
yes, these kind of semantic associations
have the best strategy, but
it doesn't make any difference
what strategy you use.
If you're a synesthete, you do better
on this particular test.
Another way of doing it
with another group is that
you actually give them a strategy.
So one is that you can process it deeply,
you make semantic judgements about words
such as whether it's
living, and the other way
is that you process it shallowly,
you ask about the letters in the word.
And again, whether or not you process it
shallowly or deeply,
synesthetes have better memory
for words here, and they produce fewer
false alarms, misrecognitions.
So here, these are verbal stimuli
that for these people elicit colors.
What about if you look at
non-verbal visual stimuli?
So these are some of the kinds
of stimuli that we presented,
so again here we would have scenes.
We would present them with,
say, a series of 30 scenes
and then a test, we'd present
them with the same scenes
and ones that are very similar,
just a little bit different.
Also, fractals or very abstract images,
which people find very hard,
they're very hard to recode verbally
or in any other particular way.
Similarly, you can have
regular colored scenes
but you can manipulate them some way,
you can reverse it, you can
flip the color for example,
or you can make objects
appear or disappear.
So this is again a difficult memory test.
What we find here is that
synesthetes outperform controls,
so here what we've got is effect size.
This is a measure of
the relative advantage
of synesthetes over controls.
Typically they have medium effect sizes,
but actually they do much better
for visual material over verbal material,
even though the visual
material is not triggering
any extra experiences for these people.
They described thinking in visual images.
For them they think in very sensory ways,
remembering events like
reliving it in your mind's eye.
And for some things they
do particularly well.
Notice for the fractals, that's actually
one of their best things, and these
are very hard for people
typically to remember.
They can hold onto visual
patterns very well.
What I would argue here
is that synesthesia
is linked to enhanced memory,
but although you might
sometimes use synesthesia as a memory aid,
there's probably
something more fundamental
in terms of the way that
their brain is wired
in terms of holding onto
visual and sensory information,
for example, in these stimuli.
What you will also see
in these studies is that
synesthetes do well on lab tests of memory
but actually their memory
isn't so phenomenal
that they're going to produce
jaw-dropping feats at a party.
Some of my colleagues
have said, "Well hang on,
"this means that these exceptional cases
"that we've talked
about, they're anomalies.
"These are the outliers,
"something different must
be going on in these cases."
And I've kind of toyed with this idea,
but actually we don't
necessarily need to look for
a different explanation for those who have
a small upward shift than for
those who have a large one.
All we have to do is just think
about the normal distribution.
Here what you've got is a shift of
half the standard deviation,
so this is at the low end
of the medium effect size, very much
the conservative end of what I presented.
So the synesthetes are
here in the light blue.
And what you can do is you can slice up
these normal distributions and ask
how many people lie in each of these ones.
Between naught and one
standard deviations,
you'll find 38% of synesthetes
and 34% of controls,
so a ratio that favors the synesthetes.
But after you move up,
in face what you find
is that it's non-linear, the synesthetes
are very much overrepresented
at the extremes here.
If you exceed this, so if you go up to
an effect size of 0.8, which
again is not unrealistic
given some of the data I've presented,
you see again that it goes
up quite astonishingly,
the amount of synesthetes you
would expect at the high end.
So if you put it another way,
if you were to give me 1000
people and you were to rank them
in terms of their memory
ability from left to right,
and you asked me, can I find a synesthete
amongst that distribution,
where would I look?
Well I could look where
the mean is, because that's
where most of the
synesthetes are numerically,
but the problem with that is that you've
also got an awful lot of non-synesthetes
who will be performing at that level.
The best place to look is actually at
the 1000th person on the
right, and statistically
that is the person most
likely to have synesthesia.
And you don't need to do the
experiment with just math.
The closest experiment
we've done is to take
a group of people who perform
in memory championships,
so there are world rankings
for doing bizarre things
like remembering the order of
a pack of cards in 35 seconds
and so on, and we were
able to test 18 of these
memory athletes and we
checked using a valid measure
of grapheme-color
synesthesia, the standard one
in the literature, and
showed that synesthetes
are very significantly
overrepresented with this group.
The prevalence of grapheme-color
synesthesia is 1 to 2%,
other types of synesthesia push it up,
and we had a group of controls that we
tried to select in a similar way.
So we've heard a little
bit about the relationship
between synesthesia and autism,
and I came to this quite skeptical.
Why would these two very
different things be related?
But they are related.
Simon Baron-Cohen and a group of Germans
were the first people to
actually show that there's
an increased incidence of
synesthesia and autism.
They took a group of people with autism
and looked for synesthesia.
We also did this ourselves, but
amongst the autistic people,
we look at those people
who have savant traits
and those who don't.
These were all high-functioning
people with autism,
by the way, so they're not at
the low end of intellectual disability.
So what we have here, both
of these groups on the left
have a clinical diagnosis
of autism, but some of
the autistic people are
reporting savant abilities,
and this includes things like
perfect pitch or calendar calculations.
These people here are far more
likely to have synesthesia
than the kind of garden variety of people
with a diagnosis of autism.
So it is linked to autism, but it seems
to be linked to special abilities.
As well as looking for
synesthetic traits amongst people
with autism, you can
look for autistic traits
amongst people with synesthesia.
So one of the things that
we did is that we took
a standard questionnaire measure of autism
that has 50 questions, and the questions
are divided into five sub-scales,
so 10 questions in each.
Four of the sub-scales actually
ask about difficulties,
so things like social skills,
which people with autism
find hard, but there's one sub-scale
that asks about abilities,
and that's attention to detail
so here this particular
question is reverse coded.
People with autism are
very good at finding
the proverbial needle in a haystack,
they do very good Where's
Waldo kind of puzzles,
detecting parts and wholes and so on.
They do good at this.
If we give this to a group of synesthetes,
again what we find, so this
is a score from naught to 50.
Controls are about 18, synesthetes
are raised significantly.
They fall quite considerably below
the average of the not-autistic person,
but actually even this
shift, what this means
if you model the tail
end of the distribution,
is that you would expect at
least twice as many synesthetes
to be overrepresented
in the tail than that,
so these small shifts can have
large effects for the tail
is one of my take-home messages.
Here, these are the five sub-scales
and it looks complicated but it isn't.
In the gray bar we've got
our group with autism,
so a high score means
you're high on the spectrum.
In blue you've got your synesthetes,
and in orange you've got your controls.
So this is social skills here.
What we can see is that
for four out of five
of these particular
things, the synesthetes
are indistinguishable from the controls,
they're a little bit above them.
But for one out of five, the synesthetes
are indistinguishable
from people with autism,
and this is in the attention
to detail sub-scale.
And we've subsequently
confirmed that using
what's called a change-blindness parallel
where you have to notice small changes
in scenes that are flickering.
Autism has been defined in
terms of these impairments,
but in the most recent
psychiatric definition,
they added a sensory symptom,
and this was sensory hypersensitivity,
and also maybe hyposensitivity.
Some of the things might
be finding bright lights
particularly aversive or giving
you a headache and so on.
People have developed
various measures of this,
again, initially using a questionnaire,
so this is the one that we used,
the Glasgow Sensory Questionnaire.
What we find here is that synesthetes
are significantly above
controls, and numerically similar
to people with autism on this measure,
despite actually not having many of
the classic signs of being autistic.
We looked at this in more
detail, so most of the people
we've looked at are these people with
grapheme-color synesthesia,
because we have
very obvious ways of
verifying this in the lab.
But we can also look at
the presence of other kinds
of synesthesia, so those people
who see time, for example,
in these kind of spatial calendars.
People who have tastes or
flavors in their mouths,
people who experience words
spelled out as they listen
to speech, some people
see it like ticker tape,
or having visual experiences to music.
What we can do, in effect,
is we can take people
and we just say, "How many
of these have you got?"
And actually, our synesthetes
were asked this question
often about three or four years ago,
when they first volunteered
and we've kept a database
of that information.
So this is what we find in
terms of sensory sensitivity.
We have a very clear dose effect between
how many types of synesthesia
somebody has and how much
they report sensory
sensitivity on this measure.
This is where people with autism are.
If you've got zero types of synesthesia,
you're our control group.
These are people with
one, two, three and four.
You can't read this at
the bottom, but these
are just different
combinations of that five.
You don't need to read it.
If you have three types of synesthesia,
that is your level of sensory
sensitivity on this measure.
This is the proportion
of people in these groups
who are at the high end
of the autism spectrum.
People with autism on this
measure typically have
a score of 32 or above,
and what you can see
is it goes up dramatically
with the more types
of synesthesia you have.
So there is a clear relationship
between synesthesia and
autism, but it's complex and
it's to do with the nature of
how synesthetic your brain is.
So, to summarize, what I
would say is that synesthesia
is linked to certain abilities,
it's linked to enhanced memory.
It's also linked to some
of the traits of autism.
It's linked to sensory sensitivity,
which I'm not sure whether that's
a positive or negative trait.
It's normally cast in
terms of a negative trait,
but whether or not that has particular ...
Whether it is linked to other
abilities, I don't know.
Attention to detail is
a clear ability that is
probably driving some of
these savant abilities to
notice patterns, to notice
details in their sensory world.
Although synesthetes
don't necessarily present
with the triad of impairments
that classically define autism,
what seems to happen is
that you have an increase
of vulnerability of getting that.
In a way, you buy into having
the advantages of autism,
but the danger is that
you are more susceptible
to getting the negative traits as well.
It's almost as if
synesthetes are occupying
a very interesting cognitive
niche, where they're
sliding up the autistic scale a little bit
and getting some of the
benefits, but they're not
falling over the cliff edge.
But you stand a risk of
doing that, of course,
just by moving up that
particular genetic niche.
So to conclude, synesthesia is linked
to basic differences in brain function.
We don't fully understand
what those differences are,
but my best guess is that it's to do with
differences in plasticity,
in holding on particularly
to sensory information over time, and also
to sensory sensitivity, both
subjectively and probably
again, in terms of cognitive processing.
Many of these traits
seem to be shared with
the positive features of autism,
abilities, savant
characteristics and so on.
Synesthesia is linked to
cognitive enhancements in memory,
but again, it doesn't seem
that synesthesia is just
simply a mnemonic device
or a cognitive tool.
Some people do use their
synesthesia in that way,
but it seems to be a deeper connection
between synesthesia and
cognitive enhancement.
And I guess in terms of
a more general conclusion
from this symposium, is that
even medium-sized effects,
so the fact that synesthetes
are shifted up by a
medium-sized effect, has profound
consequences at the tail,
that you really can
overrepresent things at the tail
because of the way that these
normal distributions go.
It might be that even though
most synesthetes aren't
exceptional, actually there's
something about synesthesia
that is really kind of driving
things at that high tail end
in the exceptional ability zone.
Thank you very much for your time.
These are my collaborators, and these are
some famous synesthetes, none
of whom I've worked with.
(applause)
(bright music)